E aí
E por que você acha que o atleta acaba
se tornando campeão do mundo
e se não temos muitos deles disputando
as finais porque apenas um se sobressai
em relação aos demais pensa comigo se a
gente comprar o campeão do mundo Alves
campeão do mundo por exemplo os dois são
talentosos certo os dois são
persistentes e se treinaram muito para
chegar até ali foram dedicados e foram
disciplinados os dois mostraram garra em
muitos momentos decisivos e os dois a
gente pode até dizer tem uma genética
diferenciada só que apenas um deles
chegou na frente apenas um deles ganhou
medalha de ouro porque eu convivi com
atletas desse nível durante muitos anos
e acabei até me tornando um deles e eu
vou contar um negócio para vocês tudo o
que eu falei antes agarra a disciplina a
dedicação a persistência o talento tudo
isso é importante mas nada disso é o
verdadeiro diferencial
é o que define quem vai chegar em
primeiro segundo terceiro e último é a
maneira como cada um deles direciona o
foco como cada um deles conversa com ele
mesmo principalmente nos momentos mais
importantes para e pensa quantas vezes
por dia Principalmente nos momentos que
você sente mais pressionado você não
conversa com você mesmo tem gente que
até ver baliza isso em voz alta e é mais
que normal o empresário que vai tomar
uma decisão importante ele reflete sobre
ela durante muitos dias o trabalhador
que juntou dinheiro vai comprar o
primeiro carro também o estudante que
vai prestar vestibular ainda nem tem
certeza qual carreira ele quer seguir
E aí vai ficar chorando durante muito
tempo será que ele está tomando decisão
certo será que é isso que ele quer para
vida dele essa comunicação interna as
palavras que a gente usa e as perguntas
que a gente faz tem um impacto enorme na
nossa cabeça e a qualidade dessa
linguagem o ponto fundamental da
alta-performance por exemplo sou nadador
vai mal no campeonato ele pode pensar o
seguinte hoje foi mal cometi muitos
erros O que é muito diferente de ele
pensar que eu nadei muito mal eu sou um
péssimo nadador
e vocês veem a diferença cada frase tem
um impacto diferente em cada frase gera
um sentimento diferente e esse
sentimento ele está diretamente ligado
Às nossas atitudes e as nossas atitudes
diretamente ligados aos nossos
resultados futuros mas não essa outra
situação dois lados estão aqui no Brasil
eles têm a mesma idade que eles na mesma
prova lá na Alemanha por exemplo o
adversário deles quebra o recorde do
mundo
é o primeiro óleo o tempo e tem seguinte
que tem posso os cara mandou eu não sei
se eu sou bom o suficiente para ganhar
dele eu não acredito que eu consigo
nadar tão rápido assim já o segundo está
na mesma situação olha para o tempo e
pensa assim que tem passo esse cara fez
filho da mãe mas se ele fez eu também
consigo'
nem preciso dizer qual dos dois vai ter
mais sucesso nesta temporada primeiro
basicamente existiu enquanto que o
segundo tem a simples crença de que se
foi feito por uma pessoa é possível pode
ser replicado pode ser feito por outras
pessoas e por que não até melhorado E
por que Não por ele mesmo Ficou claro
que esse tipo de pensamento pode ser uma
armadilha que te impede de crescer com
também pode ser uma catapulta que te
joga para cima te enche de motivação e
faz você ser cada vez mais rápido eu
vejo muito exemplos disso nas minhas
químicas que eu faço pelo Brasil também
um tema que é muito frequente é o
momento e o nervosismo pré-prova alguns
lá dores nem fala comigo eles falam
assim se eu gosto de nadar eu sinto
minhas mãos suando meu coração bate mais
rápido minha respiração acelera meus
pensamentos começam a correr mais rápido
Minha cabeça está girando e eu sei que
eu tô tendo um ataque de pânico
os outros narradores na mesma situação
eles falam assim para mim se longe
competir eu sinto minhas mãos suando eu
sinto meu pensamento acelerado mesmo
cabeça e começa a correr no Coração tá
acelerado começa a bater mais rápido
minha respiração tá mais rápida e eu sei
que tudo isso é o meu corpo me dizendo
Já estamos prontos
é tão próximos e tão distantes o fato de
pensar que vai ter um ataque de pânico
paralisa o primeiro nadador faz a
situação por causa dela desagradável
experiência fica desagradável fica ruim
aliás Este é um ponto importante para a
gente conversar é o fato e de que faz
muito jovens pararem para participar de
competições esportivas já o segundo ele
veio aquilo como um desafio ele vem as
reações do corpo dele como sinais de que
uma grande performance está chegando
e a gente não percebe mas esse tipo de
comunicação está presente na nossa vida
o tempo inteiro até mesmo na nossa
identidade você já ouviu o nadador falar
eu estou tentando nadar nunca certo o
que que ele fala eu sou um nadador
parece bobo Quantas vezes você já me
escutou tô tentando perder peso que eu
tô tentando ir para academia eu tô
tentando parar de fumar eu estou
tentando fazer dieta muitas vezes certo
a palavra tentar abre a possibilidade da
gente fazer apenas Quando é conveniente
você escuta em você mesmo leva a sério
se você pensar assim eu vou tentar parar
de comer chocolate agora lá no fundo da
sua cabeça bem um
e a hum Até parece preço seguinte o que
que é mais gostoso ficar em casa
assistindo a sua série preferida comendo
uma pipoca ou encarar as pistas encarar
oficinas encarar as quadras encarar as
reuniões encarar as suas
responsabilidades o ser humano tem uma
tendência muito grande em se acomodasse
principalmente em situações confortáveis
só que enquanto você tá aí relaxado seus
aniversários estão lá treinando ralando
E aí qual vai ser a sua postura o que
que você vai fazer qual que vai ser o
seu foco nesse momento porque eu te
garanto o campeão do mundo ele vai estar
pensando assim o que que eu preciso
fazer para ter uma grande sensação de
tema o que que eu devo comer para ter
mais energia no próximo treino
E o restante aí tá pensando assim que
que eu quero fazer no treino de hoje que
eu tô afim de comer nos Jogos Olímpicos
de Pequim eu aprendi O Poder Desse
pensamentos na prática é uma parte da
temporada de resultados ruins os treinos
não foram bons eu fui ficando cada vez
mais preocupadas que cada vez mais
preocupados com as minhas performances
na Olimpíada eu passei a temporada tô
falando para mim mesmo que eu não tava
bem eu tava fora de forma e até às vezes
eu pensei até que o destino não queria
que eu ganhasse uma medalha eu pensava
assim assim não vai dar mais um dia ruim
de treino eu nunca vou chegar na medalha
olímpica treinando assim
e eu não conseguia pensar em outra coisa
eu vivia me humilhando eu só sabia fazer
isso todo dia falar coisa negativa e
pensar coisa negativa Agora pensa nessa
loucura todo santo dia eu falando um
monte de besteira para mim mesmo um
monte de coisa ruim pensando que eu não
ia conseguir pensando que eu não merecia
o resultado disso turu e cheguei no
Olimpíadas confiança lá embaixo e na bem
mal minhas três primeiras provas no
revezamento 4 x 100 livre foi mal na
eliminatória dos 100 metros livre foi
mal para semifinal dos 100 metros livre
fui pior ainda quando na dessa semifinal
e olhei para o placar foi uma das
maiores decepções que eu sentindo a
minha carreira eu tinha certeza que eu
tava fora da final falei um monte de
coisa ruim para mim mesmo me xinguei Tá
vendo foi normal é esse resultado que
você merece você não merece estar em uma
final Olímpica muito menos ganhar uma
medalha mim estou sem ter uma ideia do
meu nível de altura quando meu treinador
vem falar comigo que eu tinha
classificado para final que eu tinha
classificado com o oitavo tempo só que
eu quero minha resposta para ele
o que bacana Alguém precisa chegar em
último amanhã deixa comigo eu me sentia
completamente derrotados antes mesmo de
nadar só que tinha uma coisa ali para
abrir os olhos eu tinha uma final
Olímpica para competir
o ponto da virada aconteceu justamente
alguns momentos antes dela sabe como
mudando a minha comunicação interna
avaliando a situação deixando aqui nos
demônios não falassem mais alto que
minha consciência Eu pensei comigo mesmo
eu tô numa final Olímpica só eu e mais
sete nadadores no mundo todo milhares de
pessoas gostaria de estar na situação
quem sabe até milhões será que eu sou um
perdedor assim
o topo tu que eu tô aqui na Raia 8 Como
que o cara que quer ficou em nono para
se sentindo ele não vai ter outra chance
e o cara que ficou em décimo
e eu tive três chance de nadar essa
prova antes 14 por ser livre a
eliminatória dos 100 livre EA semifinal
dos 100 livre nas três eu só fiz
besteira eu tenho que ser muito burro e
repetir toda a rotina que eu fiz e fazer
isso tudo de novo eu preciso mudar chega
para mim chega eu preciso mudar o que
que eu posso fazer para mudar
Oi e essa pergunta no final é o mais
importante o que que eu preciso fazer
para mudar eu comecei a buscar solução
eu podia mudar na maneira de nadar eu
podia mudar a estratégia eu podia mudar
o meu aquecimento eu podia mudar as
ativações que eu faça antes da prova
essa procura incessante por resposta
mudou completamente a ligação no foco eu
sair daquele tô fora de forma tô mal eu
não mereço ganhar para simplesmente
começar a pensar exclusivamente na minha
performance parece simples mas na
prática é uma revolução é como você tá
no quarto escuro andando e tropeçando em
tudo e de repente alguém acende a luz
E aí tudo fica claro você enxerga tudo
menos de 24 horas antes dessa prova eu
só conseguia pensar na vergonha que eu
ia passar e na péssima prova que eu ia
fazer
e de repente com essa mudança na direção
do foco a raia 8 deixou de ser ainda
vergonha deixou de ser raio na caridade
ela virou uma nova oportunidade a busca
pelo meu sonho A Busca Pela medalha
olímpica continuava viva eu tinha outra
chance e o número do meu bloco não
importava no final eu consegui fazer uma
grande prova e consegui lá da raia 8
conquistar minha sonhada medalha cheguei
em terceiro lugar empatado com o nadador
mas naquele momento esse pouco me
importava eu peguei a minha medalha e
fui fazer uma entrevista onde eu falei
que eu ia ganhar os 50 Livre
o Mc Tinho parava naquele momento
o que mudança uma pergunta pode fazer se
a gente parar para pensar a gente faz
pergunta para a gente mesmo o tempo
inteiro a diferença tá na qualidade
dessas perguntas como eu posso usar isso
ao meu favor o que que eu preciso fazer
para melhorar com esse tipo de pergunta
respostas produtivas ou aparecer na sua
cabeça por outro lado se você pensar
porque isso sempre acontece comigo por
que que eu nunca consigo por que que eu
sou tão azarado Você não vai sair do
lugar a sua comunicação interna pode
levar à glória mas também pode levar o
abismo e sabe qualquer magia disso tudo
e é você que escolhe é você que decide
qual dos dois vai querer e esse meus
amigos é o grande segredo dos atletas
que a gente conhece como decisivo nos
momentos mais críticos nos momentos de
tudo ou nada naquele último arremesso
que tá valendo jogo eles não vão pensar
e se eu errar isso eu não consegui
E eu simplesmente não pensar em fazer o
melhor que eles podem fazer eles vão se
perguntar como eu faço para deixar o meu
melhor aqui agora como eu executo a
minha melhor performance nesse momento
se você não tá acreditando se você tá
achando que é muito simples
nós vamos fazer o seguinte imagina que
você está prestes nada Vamos ser nadador
por alguns minutos
se você está prestes a competir uma
final Olímpica agora visualiza
arquibancada cheia de gente todo mundo
gritando todo mundo torcendo
e agora imagina o deck da piscina cheia
de câmeras sua prova vai ser passada no
mundo todo milhões de pessoas vão
assistir você nadar
e para fechar imagina seus adversários
você e mais sete Caras todos muito
fortes todos muito grandes todos muito
concentrados e todos querendo a medalha
que você também quer troca sua melhor
performance você precisa bloquear tudo
isso e ainda silenciar os seus medos
e agora não parece tão fácil não é mesmo
sabe como a gente faz isso direcionando
o foco com perguntas
E como eu executo a minha melhor
performance agora o que eu preciso fazer
para deixar o meu melhor nessa piscina